あえて雪待ってパワー
今日はどこああ
京都ある実験だ皆さんネットの肘とか一時ゆえにだったと思うんだからハリボーグリー
食べたことはありますかこのハリボーグミハンガーリス死の組なのだが日本でもかなり
の人気を誇っていますて基本的に今ベンドがにいれば売っているダイニングミスリード
の一つでございます彼が軽いものグミ変わる人は素晴らしい食べ方を発見したような
ネットのゲームで見たんですけどもこんな haribo グミをウイスキーの中に
つけて2日間漬け込んだところ
をとてもとてもおいしくなってしまったという記事を目指す見たことがありますうん
着替えた金棒コンボ技を避けあまり飲まないんで多分ウイス t につけた
haribo グミを食うだけでも多分僕はもう
逆に私たちのような人たちはどうやったアレを楽しめればいいのかと考えたところ私は
考えた
ウイスキー恋じゃないですかそこで濃い飲み物は何かあるかなと思ったところこちら
カルピスの原液
あっはぁ
うわっはぁ
大人たちを wiki を楽しんでれたお茶カルピスを飲んだつまりわれわれお酒が
飲めたりが楽しむこの haribo に唯一土をつけて48時間待つおいしくなると
いう作成の子供バージョンはた影結果敗北実はカルピスの原液に48時間だと甘い場合
だ
着時間作れたらどれだけ美味しくなるか実験してみると思うわー
あっはぁ
あっあっ
ああ嫌な罰ゲじゃないかそうだともうカルピスのでにとても濃いで
20ml で46kcal やるから飲み物なのにこれで1000キロカロリーぐらい
あります
あんまりレイプって飲んだ僕ないんですよいただきます
[音楽]
あそう相性いいなぁ多分見る悩みだおいしい軍になるんではないか私は仮定しています
今とても小さいんだか水をすることによってかなり巨大化するらしいのってネットに見
た兄弟はだいたい2日間48時間でちゃっていたみたいないとき私はそれの2倍100
時間約4日間ぐらいをめどに行ってみると
いやそれやってサイズ感をどれくらい変化するかということ味がどれだけこの染み込む
たてるの
あると思うので早速ず店ごとおでこあんまり人たちすぎだめみたいなので全部こうつか
ないよぐらいの量でいいみたいです
いや匂いがすごい匂いがこんなもんでいいんじゃないかなたまだいたいこれくらいで
いいと思いますでは早速ハゲ僕においていこうと思う
もうちょっとまだ浅いな
it を上げて全部入りましたこのサイズ感このファイルが皆さん覚えておいて
ください
ん
よし今から100人今から100時間になってみると思います
スバリュっ
me
油断した気づいたらあれくらいつけ館立っていたさすがにこれで木組みを政府に浸して
おくとかなりの大きさの変化が見られるのではないかと思うでは
取りに行ってこれを食べろそアーマーはをはまってまってなんかすごい
黄色くなって音ズレちゃんと成功するみたいなんですけどもうちょっと不安用途も一つ
ありましてカルピスの色が明らかおかしいんですよね
では早速取り出してみるとスプーンですくってもかなりで画面になってますまた3
プルプルしてるぷるぷる年かすごい夢かはすごいなんかうち夢か不貞の葉2本組と比べ
てもその差は歴然ですが早速食べてみると思います
抱い
ます
おます
[音楽]
さあ
ルー
うわぁ
柔らかいそして俺コレ
発明したほしいねないまあこれたぶんあれだねアルヴィスこういう意味で正解だった
パターンですねくみってそんなに水分吸収するために生まれていきましたみたいな
やっぱりじゃないのでトマトの水分の吸収率時代はそんなに高いものではないと思うん
ですけどわずかに削ってきた成分のところに両宿されたカルピスのでンって打ち込む
ことを言ってグミの味とカルピスのほどでハーモニーが建てられております11るって
入って後柔らかいん
出没してる思うためちょっとんめっちゃ甘いフルーツぜひ
あっフルーツジェリーだー
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ